here's how i want to start though i want
to discuss
what some businesses who cater to young
people are doing
to assist with the vaccination efforts
scores of businesses and organizations
have responded to the president's call
to action to volunteer their services
and help the american people to get
vaccinated
over the next few weeks we'll be
highlighting a number of outside
initiatives to provide incentives
for people to get vaccinated we believe
that it's particularly important to
reach young people where they are
in the effort to get the vaccinated we
do know that in addition to schooling
financial loss stress levels the
pandemic has also had
a negative impact on young people's
social lives
social distancing and dating were always
a bit of a challenging combination
so today dating sites like bumble
tinder hinge match okay cupid
blk chispa plenty of fish
and badoo are announcing a series of
features
to encourage vaccinations and help
people
with that universe help people meet
people who have that universally
attractive quality
they've been vaccinated against covet
19.
these sites cater to over 50 million
people in the u.s
and are some of the world's biggest
non-gaming apps
here's one for you according to one of
the sites okcupid
people who display their vaccination
status
are 14 more likely to get a match
we have finally found the one thing that
makes us all more attractive
a vaccination these dating apps will now
allow vaccinated people to display
badges which show their vaccination
status
filter specifically to see only people
who are vaccinated
and offer premium content details of
which i cannot get into
but apparently they include things like
boosts and super swipes
the apps will also help people locate
places to get vaccinated
all right got through that today also
happens to be
our digital day of action the white
house and others including michelle
obama
will be highlighting the vaccines.gov
website
and 43829
text line throughout the day
now it's been four months since
president biden's first full day of
office
things are substantially better than
they were four months ago
when we were losing thousands of
americans each day
and people were waiting weeks or more to
get vaccinated
usually not even knowing where or when
it would happen
today more than 125 million americans
are fully vaccinated
those americans who've been vaccinated
are at much lower risk
and have more of their lives back
they're able to do most
things mask free and with less reason to
socially distance
tens of millions more adding up to more
than 60 percent of the adult population
are at least partially vaccinated the
impact has been everything we could have
hoped for
given the power of vaccines across the
country
cases of covet 19 serious illness
and loss of life are all down
dramatically from when we arrived
and they can be brought down even
further and the risk of a future wave in
your community
significantly reduced if we keep up the
pace of vaccinations
many americans have still not gotten
vaccinated
most of them younger many of them not
opposed to vaccination
they simply haven't prioritized it it
has never been easier
starting monday when you text 438-829
not only will you instantly see where
vaccines near you are available
you will also be offered a free ride
there and back
more employers are offering paid time
off to get vaccinated
and as we discussed today there are
clear benefits to your social life
most importantly you'll be protected
from a virus which is still
racing around the world i will now hand
it over to dr wolinski
thank you good morning i'm pleased to be
back with you today
let's begin with an overview of the data
yesterday cdc reported a little
over 27 850 new cases of covet 19.
our seven-day average is about 27 700
cases per day
this represents yet another decrease of
more than 19
from the prior seven-day average and
also marks the second day in a row where
our seven day average is less than 30
000 cases per day the last time the
seven day average of cases per day was
this low
was june 18 2020
the seven day average of hospital
admissions is slightly over 3 400
a decrease of almost 15 percent from the
previous seven day period and another
positive trend and the seven day average
of daily deaths has also declined
to a new low of 498 per day
at the start of each briefing over the
past few weeks i have shared with you a
snapshot of the data
and more recently the encouraging
decreases in cases
hospitalizations and deaths as each week
passes
and as we continue to see progress these
data give me hope
i also know that these snapshots are
hard to put into the context
after 16 months of reviewing them in
isolation each data point does not tell
the full story of what we are seeing
across the country
today i'd like to give you a bit of a
deeper dive into the data
and to share with you ways you can
understand the progress your community
is making
each day cdc in collaboration with
partners across the government
releases a community profile report and
updates our
county level data on covet data tracker
when we look at covet case incidents at
the county level
we see major decreases as i've mentioned
at the start of my remarks we have seen
a
20 decrease in the seven day average of
cases across the country
and we have seen some counties across
the country have had an
even greater decrease including
decreases of 25
in more and or more in just the past
week
each week we also see a release of an
assessment of county level
transmission risk taking into account
rate covett rates and cova 19 test
characteristics
and we have used this transmission risk
for many of our cdc
guidance materials for example our
school guidance
importantly over the past month there
has been a steady decline in the number
of counties in the united states with a
high risk of community transmission
and more and more counties are moving to
low or moderate transmission categories
we now have 307 counties or 10
of the entire us in which we would
characterize having low
transmission and there are 1183 counties
or 37
of all u.s counties in the moderate
transmission category
which we define as less than 50 cases
per 100 000 in the last seven days
now if you look at this news slide up i
want to show you two maps of our country
one from january and one from this week
cdc uses data on cases and county
transmission to help us
understand areas across the country
where we may have
concern for emerging or sustained
outbreaks and where things have markedly
improved
and also to understand the burden of
infection at the local level
because we recognize that these
decisions have to be made
locally when we look across the country
our areas of high
or moderate burden indicated by red and
pink respectively
are shrinking and areas with low burden
of disease
indicated by light green are markedly
increasing
many of the areas where previous high
and moderate burden
are now resolving and are highlighted on
blue in this map
the map on the right demonstrates our
national landscape that
things are improving and we are seeing
this week
after week and with more and more green
over time
these data are telling us a story as
more and more people
roll up their sleeves and get vaccinated
the number of cases and the level of
community risk
is decreasing i want to thank everyone
who has done their part to bring us
where we are today
with more than 60 percent of americans
18 and older having received at least
one dose
and being on their way to full
vaccination and 126.6 million
americans who are fully vaccinated the
progress in these data are so
encouraging to me
and i hope encouraging to you and i
know our work here is not done we still
have many more people to get vaccinated
i encourage everyone who is not yet
fully vaccinated
to visit vaccine.gov and find a location
to get your first
or second shot thank you i'll now turn
things over to dr fauci
thank you very much dr wolinski i'd like
to spend the next couple of minutes
just underscoring and emphasizing the
reasons why
dr wolenski was able to show you such
promising data
and that is real world effectiveness
of the over 19 vaccine and bringing you
up to date
on some of the day that confirms the
things that we've been telling you over
the last
several press briefings next slide this
is an mmwr from the cdc
which is looking both at the fisa
bioentec
and the modern vaccine among healthcare
personnel at 33
sites in the united states again if you
look at the
effectiveness in the real world setting
again
right at the point that we saw with the
clinical trials
usually real world settings have less of
an efficacy
than in the trials as i've mentioned
many times not so here
94 against symptomatic disease
next slide if you look at a very
interesting study
that came out two days ago in the new
england journal of medicine
looking at the incident of sauce kobe 2
infection
in nursing home residents in those who
were either vaccinated
or unvaccinated we see a very
interesting
phenomenon among the 13 000
residents who were vaccinated who
received two doses
there was a one percent infection within
zero to 14 days of the second dose and
practically no infections namely
0.3 after 14 days
note that 80 of the cases
were asymptomatic among vaccinated
individuals something that we have seen
in other situations
next slide on the other side of the coin
are those in this same study
who were unvaccinated if you look at the
infection rate
of those individuals within 0 to 14 days
after the first
clinic they were four point three
percent
compared to the very small one percent
in the previous slide and they were
0.3 percent if you waited more than 42
days
this is a reflection of what is likely
a mini version within the nursing home
setting
of herd immunity next slide
and then another multi-state mayo clinic
health system study where you looked at
adenovirus
uh vector mainly the j and j i've been
speaking to you up to now
about the mrnas so after at least two
weeks
of follow-up the vaccine effectiveness
again
was even greater in the united states
here
than we originally reported with the 72
next slide again more data
this was a j paper that i showed to this
group
a few weeks ago looking at the safe in
the efficacy
of the single dose at 26.
as you can see the efficacy was 74
in the united states but now take a look
at this a little bit more closely next
slide
if you look at the hospitalizations and
compare the placebo in red
with the j and j in blue 14 days
post-vaccination you see there's 93
percent
vaccine efficacy but if you wait at
least
28 days post-vaccination
it's a hundred percent with regard to
hospitalizations
next slide and then
when you look at deaths there were no
covet 19 related deaths in the vaccine
group
and five covet related deaths in the
placebo group
and on the final slide what does this
tell us
that vaccines protect you they protect
your family
and they interrupt the chain of
transmission of the virus
so the bottom line is we're all saying
get
vaccinated pass it over to you dr murthy
well thank you so much dr fauci and it's
good to be with all of you again this
morning
i'd like today to share some numbers
with you concerning people who are
vaccinated and unvaccinated
the recent data from the cdc involving a
survey of over 14
000 people showed that more than 70
percent of americans are vaccinated
planning to get vaccinated or likely to
get vaccinated
and while a portion of the unvaccinated
population do have questions
about the vaccine and while we are going
to continue to mobilize
trusted messengers to our kovind 19
community corps to help
answer these questions the truth is that
overall vaccine confidence in the
country
remains high that is good news the data
continues to point though to access
barriers being an important
additional concern among people who are
unvaccinated
there's a recent kaiser family
foundation survey
which looked at people those who are
unvaccinated but who wanted to get
vaccinated as soon as possible
what it found was that more than a third
of people in this group said that they
have not gotten vaccinated because they
didn't have enough time due to work
hours or other scheduled conflicts
or because they just hadn't gotten
around to it but seven percent of people
said that they didn't have
information about how to get vaccinated
eight percent said they weren't sure if
they were eligible or had the right
documentation
these numbers may seem small but they
actually represent millions of people
and they are crucial to reach with
vaccines if you want
cases that come down and stay down now
when we look at another part of the
unvaccinated population
those who do not want to get vaccinated
as soon as possible
it turns out here too access is an issue
among those who are employed 28
say that they would be more likely to
get vaccinated if they receive
time off to receive and recover from the
vaccine another 20
say they would be more likely if the
shot was administered in their workplace
so employers not only have an
opportunity to increase vaccination
rates
but if you look at one more piece of
data it turns out that they can also
help to close the equity gap in
vaccinations
this is so important because we've said
from the beginning that success is not
just determined
by how many people we get vaccinated but
by high equitably and fairly
we vaccinate our population and
workplaces it turns out can play a role
in that
because among the unvaccinated 64
of hispanic adults and 55 of black
adults
have concerns about missing work to
recover from vaccinations
compared to 41 of white adults
and that's why the recently announced
tax credits for businesses and
non-profit organizations with fewer than
500 employees
are so important because they provide
financial support for businesses
providing time off for employees
to actually get the vaccine and recover
from temporary side effects
we want people to know about this we
want businesses to take advantage of it
this next phase of the vaccination
campaign will will be driven
more than anything by the people and
organizations and communities who help
to vaccinate their families
their friends and others in their
neighborhoods it's why we've been saying
that addressing
access motivation and vaccine confidence
requires
an all hands on deck approach but
thankfully people all across america are
stepping up to meet this moment
businesses like joe's kansas city
barbecue are giving workers
time off if they get vaccinated and the
phoenix zoo is administering vaccines
on-site to visitors volunteers and
employees
young invincibles a young adult advocacy
group and a member of our kobe 19
community corps
recently launched don't miss out la
a campaign that trains young people to
spread the word about the vaccine on all
fronts
peer-to-peer texting phone banking
social media
qr code stickers placed in popular la
spots
and of course the good old-fashioned
in-person conversation
and parents together another one of our
kobe 19 community corps members which is
a
parent-led and parent-powered
organization which provides trusted
information to families
they have engaged hundreds of thousands
of patients of parents online
about their questions about vaccines any
concerns they may have and stories
about their vaccinations so today we are
asking everyone
to help spread the word about getting
vaccinated as part of our digital day of
action
uh and we are encouraging communities to
visit vaccine.gov
to text their zip code to 438829
which spells getbacks or j822862 which
spells
and you can find available vaccines near
you
so please reach out to your family and
friends please share this with
the members of your organization whether
it's your employees or your volunteers
remind people the vaccine is free of
charge it's now
easier to get than ever before and
remind people also
that the vaccine remains our single best
pathway
out of the kobe 19 pandemic thank you so
much and i'll turn it back to andy
thank you dr murthy okay we'll take some
questions
thanks andy and happy friday uh let's go
to victoria night at
kaiser
hey thanks for taking my question my
question is for dr wilinski
will the cdc be updating their dashboard
daily with state by state race and
ethnicity data
and also what is the cdc planning to do
about
the high percentage of missing data on
race and ethnicity which is close to
about 40 percent thank you for that
question victoria um
we have been updating our website i
can't say that it's daily i believe that
it's weekly and we actually have a new
uh new um feature just in the last week
looking at um how we are doing for
vaccine uh distribution
in a two two-week rolling basis um we
are working actively with states uh
public health and localities to
um try and get more access to race and
ethnicity data
um and have actually made some progress
in that regard and we're continuing to
do so
next question steve portnoy cbs
hi thanks for taking my question um all
of the data that
the doctors have laid out this morning
is extremely encouraging but
some people saw the crowd of close to 70
presumably fully vaccinated people in
the east room at the white house
yesterday
and some said on social media that the
site made them nervous so to the doctors
what do you say to those people who may
have spent the last 15 months following
your advice to strictly avoid crowds
who might not be psychologically ready
to do what you now know to be safe if
they've been vaccinated
dr fauci are these lingering fears
irrational and to dr
wolenski what does it say about the
response to the cdc's communications
over the last week if people do continue
to have that fear
dr fauci you want to begin well i would
say that
fears like that are not irrational i
mean i mean people
it's understandable when you're used to
a certain type of behavior
and then when the science says that you
can actually
turn around that as we've said with the
recent
cdc guidelines that say we can feel
comfortable
that if you're fully vaccinated that you
are safe from being infected be it
outdoors or indoors you can understand
that when people have been following a
certain trend for a considerable period
of time
that it may take time for them to adjust
so i would not say
that that's irrational i'd say that's
understandable
director will escape thank you i i would
echo much of what dr falchi has said
you know when we released our guidelines
in this and the science said it was safe
to do so we
also acknowledge that um not everybody
is going to feel like it's time to rip
off their masks for 16 months we've been
saying that it's important to wear these
masks to protect yourselves
and now what we're saying is um it's
going to be hard to get back to
um to you know life as we knew it
without these masks and we're going to
do so
tipping our dipping our toe in the water
and having everybody move at their own
pace we specifically
have acknowledged that um if you are
vaccinated there is no shame no problem
in continuing to wear
your mask and and just like it has been
hard to
to have everybody get masked i think
this is going to take some time for us
all to get used to
great next question peter sullivan the
hill
hi thanks um i wanted to ask about the
uh vaccine
lottery incentive program some states
have been doing ohio
new york and maryland all have
you know lotteries or prize money you
can be entered in if you vaccinate
i wonder if you kind of think that's a
good idea and have you been
talking to states about that are you
going to encourage
more states um to have these kind of
lottery incentives
well from the data we've seen they
appear to be working and i think the
reason they work
is because the vast number of people who
are not yet vaccinated
are actually not opposed to getting
vaccinated
they're just not prioritizing it very
high um
there are other things going on in their
lives and so things that draw attention
to it uh like like the lotteries in
those states you mentioned
um are not surprisingly very effective
and so we're enthusiastic
next question jeremy diamond cnn
hey thanks for taking the question um i
i'm wondering how do you all anticipate
that declining deaths and cases will
affect people's decision to get
vaccinated
um especially for those who are still on
the fence and then secondly i'm
wondering if you guys have an update on
uh the doses that you plan to send
abroad
what the timing for that is and if
you've settled on a process for deciding
which countries will get
uh doses and how many thanks so why
don't we
start with the first question which is
the impact of
the improving outlook or the pandemic on
uh on people's willingness and interest
of getting back to the dr murphy
do you want to start with that sure
thanks andy and
jeremy i appreciate the question i think
it's a good one look
it can be easy to look at the
circumstances right now with all the
improvements doctor wants he laid out in
cases hospitalizations deaths and think
we're out of this pandemic we don't have
to
get vaccinated to take precautions
anymore but that would not be the right
lesson
to take the the right message we believe
is that
we are seeing improvements because
people have in fact gotten vaccinated
and if we continue on this path get more
people vaccinated we can sustain
that decline in cases that we've seen in
the declining debts and hospitalizations
but if we stop where we are right now if
people do not get
fully vaccinated the millions more out
there who still need to uh then we will
still be at risk
potentially for more infections in the
future and we want to protect everybody
in our country from this fire so that's
why we will continue to emphasize
uh that we should keep moving forward
with vaccinations do not let your guard
down
but be can you be encouraged and
cautiously optimistic that we are
absolutely heading in the right
direction we just can't
we can't take our foot off the
accelerator
yeah there's good evidence and people
don't feel at risk of dying of the
measles yet they still get their
vaccination
so i think we just have a much more
continued education
of the public to do and many many more
people will get vaccinated
jeremy your other question uh which i
think you ask frequently
is about the um the the status of doses
to other
countries um to confirm uh
that um we have committed
that uh before the fourth of july and we
were waiting on fda approval 80 million
doses of which is 13 of all of the doses
that have been procured in the u.s are
going to be sent overseas
that's in addition to the four billion
dollar commitment
uh that we've led with kovacs um and
uh so um we are uh
we don't have a status yet on either the
fda
approval of the astrozenica doses
and nor do we have news to report today
about where those doses are going
but i will reiterate something the
president said which is that those
decisions are being made on two factors
science and public health and equity
and no other factors next question
ringgroppy usa today
hi can you talk a little bit about how
the dating app
initiative came about and also whether
this is the first for the white house to
get involved in dating sites
i suppose i have to take that question
huh um
well call you andy thanks everybody um
you know um as we were talking about
earlier in all seriousness people are
interested in other things in life
besides their vaccine um but the vaccine
enables people to get
back to the things that they enjoy in
life and you know
dr murphy's written extensively uh in
all seriousness about the concept of
loneliness and about social contact and
so forth
and so while it is a kind of a funny
thing to talk about
um the truth of the matter is people do
want to get back to their normal lives
they do have questions about uh making
sure that
um that they can do that safely and
that's great so we are we're uh we're
obviously pleased with that and
the fact that this reaches uh that those
many people you know i think
i i applaud the initiative on these
companies parts i think uh it's
it's their effort and you know we and we
had conversations with them but this is
things that they were
that that they're that they were doing
because they they saw a need
in their audience base so i think that's
i think that's the gist of it
next question tom christopher
sorry i have trouble with this unmute
button um
okay well thanks for doing this and uh
you know i i have a question i
i kind of hate to bring this up but i
really have feel like i have to
um i don't know if you guys saw this
viral video from ricky schroeder earlier
in the week yelling at some poor guy at
costco
but um i also i live in new jersey
another state that hasn't dropped
the mask mandates and uh you know
it's been bad all along but it's gotten
even worse since the new uh
vaccination the guidelines for
vaccinated people you know people come
down here on the weekends and in the
summer time
and they scream at our restaurant
workers because they have to wear a mask
to go from the door to their table
and um you know i'm just i'm wondering
what you guys have to say about all that
and
i mean i know governor phil murphy says
that you know it's not fair to ask
a frontline worker to decide whether or
not someone
presenting themselves out of business is
vaccinated or not
and so what do you think about all that
i mean
this uh a friend of mine told me that a
customer
threatened to get her fired because she
asked him to wear a mask
thanks for the question look the last
year and a half has been in one of the
most intense periods
in our lives people are feeling a lot of
stress
and they're feeling um as dr
fauci said earlier very you know normal
feelings adjusted
let's just treat each other with respect
next question
last question let's go to meg tyrell at
cnbc
well thanks um i was intrigued by what
dr murphy said about
how employers could play a bigger role
in helping people get vaccinated
um what would you like to see in terms
of them offering on-site
vaccination clinics and what do you see
as the barriers for
employers uh to be able to do that and
if i could
add just a second question uh for dr
fountain or dr wolenski
you know there's been a lot of focus on
immunocompromised folks and the fact
that vaccines may not provide the same
protection for them
do you see um monoclonal antibodies
potentially being
used for those folks preventively is
that a
potential good option um for people who
don't get so much protection from the
vaccines
let me let me let me let me start
because i do have um
we've been tracking very closely here
how employers
and hi mag thanks for the question um
how employers are in fact
creating nearsight and on-site clinics
um they're creating
uh they're either doing this on their
own through the states or they're
creating partnerships with some of the
pharmaceutical companies
um i'm sorry not pharmaceutical
companies pharmacies
who are who are capable of providing
that capability
we have begun a process um which we
might talk about at some point where we
are helping to match up
employers who have lots of employees on
their sites with people
who provide those services and we think
it's fairly commonplace i'm not sure we
have any data
on this but but it's a great thing for
an employer to do and if you're an
employer out there
i would strongly encourage you to do
this as well as giving your employees
time off
um to the dr murphy did you have
anything you wanted to add
about that before i turn to dr fauci
sure well thanks andy and
mike thanks for the question i would
just say look we really think employers
can play a powerful role here
the goal here is to bring back things
closer where people are workplaces are
obviously a place where people spend a
lot of time
and workplaces can help in in three ways
by
helping build vaccine confidence by
sharing information
by motivating people to get vaccines
both by encouraging them and also
enabling other people to share their
vaccination story
and also by improving access these are
three concrete ways the barriers though
that we often see is number one
employers may may not always know that
about just how important role they can
play and what they can do they may
wonder about
logistically how to arrange it whether
it's a partnership with a pharmacy or
what materials to share
and they also may may wonder if it's
actually working and this is one of the
reasons why
not only we set up the tax credit
program and other uh you know other
tools but we built the kobe 19 community
core is to provide a community where
people can
share best practices support one another
and take these sort of innovative
measures uh
and steps that will help bring vaccines
closer to where people are
droughty i believe the second question
meg asked was about
the use of monoclonals as prophylaxis
yeah well certainly it is a this is an
issue that we are concerned about
is people who are immuno suppressed
particularly profoundly immunosuppressed
such as some of the solid organ
transplant patients but also others
who might have autoimmune diseases who
are receiving
a variety of immunosuppressive agents we
are doing a major study
here at niaid on just those individuals
to determine what the best approach is
whether an additional boost the idea
of monoclonal antibodies is a reasonable
idea it has not been
studied in that context where you give
people
monoclonal antibody because again given
the half-life of these antibodies
you would have to give them over a
period of time whether or not it would
be feasible
to have people who in fact don't have a
good immune response
to be given monoclonal antibody every
several months
but it's certainly something worth
addressing
and worth studying one of the other ways
of approaching it
which is in the arena of therapy is to
try and get
some therapies particularly direct
acting anti-viral
agents so that when people who are in
that category of immunosuppressed
actually do get infected you can treat
them immediately so that they don't
progress
or even the way we've done with hiv
to give actually prophylaxis so there
are a lot of different options meg
that are being pursued because we do
really feel that this is a substantial
problem that we need to address and
maybe in an upcoming
uh session uh we'll highlight the status
of the trials of the
antivirals um at the right time uh
anyway thank you all have a very happy
friday and a great weekend